See the line where the sky meets the sea?
It’s got uranium in it.
Hey there drifters, Julian here for DNews.
There was a time, just after the second World
War, when atomic power held the promise of
limitless energy for the future.
It’s never lived up to that promise, partly
because nuclear power has something of an
image problem, but also because that limitless
source of power isn’t limitless, at least
not the way we get it now, mining the earth
for uranium.
With that in mind, researchers at Stanford
University have developed a new way to extract
uranium from seawater, bringing us closer
to nuclear power that can sustain us for 10,000
years.
The idea is not a new one.
Uranium makes up a teeny percentage of the
particles in the ocean, about 3 parts per
billion or the roughly equivalent of a grain
of salt dissolved in a liter of water.
The thing about the ocean is there’s a whole
lot of it, about 1.3 sextilion liters, or
13 with twenty zeroes after it.
That’s a whole lot of uranium just drifting
around when it could be powering your fridge,
so since the 90s, Japan has been developing
methods to pull it out of the water, with
the United States and China following suit.
Uranium exists in water bonded to two oxygen
atoms in a molecule called uranyl - try to
be mature about the name, guys.
Uranyl has a positive charge, so previous
methods of extraction took advantage of this.
To capture the uranyl, long strands of plastic
coated in a chemical with a negative charge
called amidoxime were left underwater for
a month, where they would passively soak up
that uranium goodness.
Then the strands would be brought to the surface,
where an acid bath would free the uranyl and
regenerate the fibers so they could be put
back in the ocean and used again.
It’s literally rinse and repeat.
So far, so amazing.
But the problem is the process hasn’t been
cost effective enough.
Even with serious improvements in the last
5 years that have reduced the cost of uranium
extraction by a factor of 4, this method still
produces uranium at the cost of about 440
dollars per kilogram.
The current method of finding a big deposit
of uranium and scooping it out of the earth
is much more cost effective, yielding uranium
for anywhere from 22 to 260 dollars per kilo.
The new method developed by Stanford should
drop prices even further.
It works by combining amidoxime with a conductive
carbon nanoparticles and applying pulses of
electricity, drawing more charged uranyl ions
to the fibers.
By the time the old fibers with just amidoxime
would be fully saturated, the new ones had
soaked up 9 times more uranyl and still had
room for more!
This could make fuel for nuclear power truly
limitless and much more accessible.
It’s estimated that we can only mine uranium
from the earth for about another 100 years
before we’ve used it up, and the countries
with significant reserves are Australia, Canada,
Kazakhstan, and Russia.
Meanwhile since the ocean is so huge and it’s
constantly dissolving rocks that release more
uranium into the water, the ocean’s supply
can meet global energy demands for 10,000
years, and the ocean is accessible to anyone
with a coastline.
That’s why this new method developed at
Stanford is so exciting; it brings limitless
nuclear power a step closer to reality.
Nuclear power still has other hurdles, like
waste disposal and a serious public image
problem.
But if we’re going to shift away from CO2-emitting
energy sources like coal and natural gas,
we’re still going to need something that
can be turned on and off to meet changing
demands.
Nuclear power can do just that, and the oceans
can sustain it far into the future.
You may be surprised to learn that you’ve
gone swimming with uranium if you’ve ever
taken a dip in the ocean.
Sometimes radiation isn’t as scary as we
make it out to be, like the radiation from
the fukushima disaster.
Trace has thoughts on that here.
So do you think this is the future of nuclear
power?
Are you a Thorium die-hard?
Or does nuclear scare the pants off you?